Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
Et dire que la vitesse de la lumière est
de 300 000 kilomètres par seconde
et que moi, il me faut toujours
une demi-heure pour trouver le bouton.
Ah !
(Applaudissements)
C’est mieux avec de la lumière,
n’est-ce pas ?
Ça évoque quoi d’ailleurs
pour vous le mot « lumière » ?
Je crois que pour la plupart d’entre nous,
la lumière, c’est d’abord
ce qui nous éclaire.
Et en cela, c'est déjà pas mal.
Pourtant, ce qui me ferait plaisir, c’est
que, ce soir, en sortant de cette salle,
vous ayez compris qu’avec de la lumière,
on peut faire bien plus encore.
C’est avec de la lumière qu’il y a
trois ans, avec Xavier et Aurélien,
nous avons pu créer ce genre d'images.
Ça vous fait penser à quoi ?
Une nuit d’orage de printemps, peut-être ?
Non, ce n'est pas ça.
Cette image a été créée à partir d’une
propriété très spéciale de la lumière :
sa cohérence.
La cohérence, cela fait bientôt
20 ans que je l’étudie.
Je suis chercheuse en aérospatiale.
Dès le début de ma carrière, j’ai souhaité
étudier l’environnement de la planète.
Pour moi, cela passait par faire des
images de ses poumons - les forêts.
Le problème avec la forêt,
quand on la regarde depuis le ciel,
à partir de l’espace,
c’est qu’on ne voit
quasiment que les feuilles.
Et pourtant, on aimerait pouvoir
décrire bien plus encore :
les branches, les troncs, les sous-bois.
Pour cela, on va utiliser
une onde électromagnétique radar.
C’est une lumière aussi, seulement
sa longueur caractéristique de vibration,
celle que l’on appelle la longueur d’onde,
est 1 million de fois plus grande
que celle de la lumière visible.
Ces ondes radar possèdent elles aussi
une propriété spéciale de cohérence.
Cela signifie que,
à n’importe quel instant,
je suis capable de décrire précisément
la position de ses bosses et de ses creux.
Je suis également capable de décrire
l'orientation de sa vibration.
Celle que l'on appelle la polarisation.
Mais si, la polarisation,
vous l’avez déjà croisée.
Vous savez, quand vous allez
dans un magasin de lunettes de soleil
et que vous êtes à la recherche de la
petite étiquette « Filtre polarisant ».
Eh bien, c'est exactement la même chose.
Avec un filtre polarisant, on va
sélectionner l'orientation de la vibration
de telle sorte à supprimer les reflets du
soleil sur les surfaces pour mieux voir.
Avec nos forêts,
c’est exactement la même chose.
On cherche à trouver
les orientations de vibration
qui nous permettent
de voir plus en profondeur.
Un jour, j’ai assisté à un séminaire
de quelqu’un de passionnant :
Antonello.
Antonello, vous savez, c’est ce genre
de chercheur tellement humble
que, quand il nous écoute,
nous petits chercheurs débutants,
il nous donne l’impression
d’être des prix Nobel.
Alors qu’en réalité, on sait très bien que
c’est lui qui mériterait le prix Nobel.
Antonello, lui aussi, étudiait les
propriétés de polarisation de la lumière,
seulement à une tout autre échelle,
derrière son microscope,
dans l’infiniment petit.
Pourtant, je me suis aperçue
à cette occasion
que les chercheurs de son domaine
n’utilisaient pas du tout
les mêmes outils théoriques et ne
parlaient pas le même langage que moi.
Alors j'ai fait cette chose un peu folle.
Je suis allé le rencontrer
et je lui ai proposé qu’ensemble,
on s’amuse à trouver tous les liens
entre nos deux échelles :
l’infiniment petit et l’infiniment grand.
Et c’est ainsi
que nous avons réalisé nos toutes
premières images polarimétriques
de ce genre de forêt.
Alors oui, ces arbres ont
une allure un peu étrange.
Ils ne sont pas si faciles
que ça à trouver
parce qu’ils mesurent exactement
1 million de fois moins
que les arbres de nos forêts classiques.
En réalité, ce sont
des nanotubes de carbone.
C’est une technologie
qui est utilisée en recherche,
principalement dans
le domaine des matériaux,
notamment pour essayer de mettre au point
des fibres textiles
innovantes intelligentes.
Autant vous dire que d’ordinaire,
les gens ne s’amusent pas du tout comme
nous à essayer de faire des mini-forêts.
Pourtant, c’est bien de cette manière
que nous avons réussi à mieux comprendre
le rôle de la polarisation
pour voir à l’intérieur de la végétation.
Et ça, ce n’était que
le tout début de l’aventure
de la convergence entre
l’infiniment petit et l’infiniment grand.
Il y a trois ans, Xavier, un ami,
m'appelle au téléphone
pour prendre des nouvelles.
Xavier, c’est un ami,
mais c’est aussi un collègue qui travaille
dans le domaine de l’optique.
« Élise, je voulais te parler
de ce que je fais en ce moment.
C’est super rigolo : je fais des images,
des vidéos, de la peau.
Pour tout te dire, je crois que j’ai
trouvé un moyen d’utiliser la polarisation
qui fait qu’on voit des trucs
qui bougent à l’intérieur.
Écoute, tu devrais regarder,
c’est assez marrant. »
La vidéo que m’avait envoyée
Xavier à l’époque, c’est celle-ci.
Oui, je pense qu'il y a un petit effet de
déception sur certains de vos visages.
Et pourtant, Xavier, devant cette vidéo,
il me dit, devant mon air sceptique :
« Ah si, Élise, je t’assure,
si tu plisses les yeux.
si tu secoues un peu la tête
de gauche [à droite],
on voit des choses
qui bougent à l’Intérieur. »
Eh bien Xavier,
il a raison.
Pour toute vidéo cryptée,
il existe un décodeur.
Xavier, pour créer ces images,
il va utiliser
la lumière d’un laser cohérent.
Si vous vous rappelez bien,
une lumière cohérente, c’est une lumière
qui est bien ordonnée.
Lorsque cette lumière va entrer
en interaction avec une surface,
toutes les micro-irrégularités
de la surface vont faire que,
quand les ondes vont se réfléchir,
elles vont rentrer en interférence
et cela va se traduire
dans les images par cet ensemble
de petites taches noires et blanches
qui semblent aléatoirement réparties.
Si vous voulez, une image,
c’est comme quand une goutte
tombe dans une flaque d’eau,
ça va créer une jolie onde bien ordonnée.
Si c'est une averse, vous allez vite vous
apercevoir que la surface est chaotique.
Mais seulement, quand la surface
en dessous de la lumière
est animée d’un mouvement,
on va s’apercevoir que la position des
petites taches fluctue différemment.
Et l’on est capable de relier
par des équations statistiques
la manière dont ces taches vont bouger et
la vitesse de la surface sous la lumière.
C’est de cette manière
que l’on établit le décodeur
qui va nous permettre de transformer
la vidéo de Xavier en cette image.
Il s’agit de la microcirculation
sanguine du visage de Xavier,
le motif très fin de ses vaisseaux
sanguins sous la peau.
Je ne sais pas vous, mais moi,
ma microcirculation,
je ne l’avais jamais vue.
On me l’avait toujours cachée.
On se dit bien, quand on se blesse
et que le sang coule,
que ce sang vient de quelque part.
De là à imaginer toute la richesse
de ses motifs et de ses vaisseaux.
C’est pour ça qu’on a eu l’idée,
qu’on a eu l’envie,
de développer un appareil qui permette
de produire ce genre d’images
pour les partager et les montrer
au plus grand nombre.
Cet appareil, nous
l’avons fait avec Aurélien.
Aurélien, c’est un troisième collègue
qui, dès le premier jour
où je lui ai montré ces images,
a eu tout de suite envie de jouer avec.
Nous, avec Xavier, ça nous arrangeait bien
car c’est ce genre de geek qui arrive
à résoudre en une seule ligne de code
des problèmes qui nous
prennent plus d’un mois.
Alors aujourd’hui,
ces images, elles sont utilisées par des
médecins chercheurs en milieu hospitalier
pour détecter précocement
les cancers de la peau.
Pourquoi ? Parce que lorsque
des cellules sont cancéreuses,
elles vont avoir un métabolisme
un peu détraqué,
elles vont faire un appel en nutriments
et en oxygène très important,
et cela va se traduire par la mise en
place d’un réseau de vascularisation dédié
pour les nourrir.
Et ce sont ces vaisseaux
que l’on détecte dans nos images.
D’autres chercheurs
vont utiliser ces images
pour mettre au point
des thérapies innovantes.
Eux, au contraire,
ils vont chercher à vérifier
si, lorsqu’ils utilisent une molécule,
ce réseau va disparaître ou s’atténuer.
D'autres chercheurs encore vont l'utiliser
dans le domaine de la greffe de peau.
À cette occasion, on s’est aperçu que
presque tous nos mécanismes physiologiques
étaient reliés de près ou de loin
à notre microcirculation
et que cela promettait
beaucoup d’applications.
À nous de découvrir lesquelles.
Il y a quelques mois, nous étions en train
de faire des images de blessures
lorsque, tout d’un coup, Julien
est rentré dans la pièce.
Alors Julien, maître zen,
le calme envahit l’espace.
Julien est chirurgien cardiaque.
Il nous a demandé si,
avec notre appareil, on serait capable
de faire des images de circulation
d’un cœur en état de battement.
Pourquoi ? Parce que dans son laboratoire,
lorsqu’ils font une greffe de cœur,
pour conserver le greffon, ils le placent
dans un appareil spécial
qui va maintenir le cœur
en état de battement,
sous perfusion,
en état de circulation sanguine.
Parce qu’on pressent que de cette manière,
cela va permettre de conserver le greffon
avec les meilleures qualités
et donc les meilleures chances
de longévité de la greffe.
On aurait pu dire à Julien :
« Écoute, Julien, ça va être difficile
parce que notre appareil est prévu pour
fonctionner sur une petite zone de peau,
à plat.
Pendant l’acquisition, on demande
au patient de ne pas bouger.
Là, le cœur, il est tout sauf plat.
Et on peut difficilement lui demander
de s’arrêter de bouger. »
Au lieu de ça, on a répondu :
« Écoute, ça a l’air vachement amusant,
ton truc, on aimerait bien regarder. »
Et c’est ainsi que nous avons produit
nos premières images de circulation
sanguine d’un cœur qui bat.
Alors,
que de chemin parcouru depuis les toutes
premières images de circulation sanguine
que m’avait envoyées Xavier.
Vous savez, les éclairs du début.
Vous savez ce qui me sidère
le plus là-dedans ?
C’est qu’il y a trois ans,
quand Xavier m’envoyait
ses premières images de circulation,
moi aussi, je venais de produire
mes premières images de circulation.
Celles que vous voyez sur votre droite.
Seulement, ce n’est pas
de la circulation sanguine,
c'est de la circulation fluviale.
Je venais de mettre au point un algorithme
qui permet de visualiser très rapidement,
sur l’ensemble de la planète,
l’ensemble de l’activité humaine.
Ici, c’est une zone en Chine,
près de Canton
où l’on peut voir l’étalement urbain et la
circulation des bateaux sur les fleuves.
Et tout cela grâce
à une vidéo d’images radar
et du décodeur basé
sur leur propriété de cohérence.
Et si finalement, dans tout ça,
le plus important, ce n’était pas les
propriétés de cohérence de la lumière ?
Et si c’était plutôt que
la recherche, comme la vie,
c’est un ensemble de chemins, une
succession de carrefours et de rencontres
avec des personnes - Antonello,
Xavier, Aurélien, Julien -
qui partagent tous la même vision de la
recherche, la même envie de s’amuser,
avec moi et aussi, comme
le dit l’écrivain Isaac Asimov :
« La phrase la plus excitante
à entendre en science,
celle qui annonce les grandes découvertes,
ce n’est pas ‘Eurêka !’,
mais c’est :
‘C’est amusant.’ »
Merci.
(Applaudissements)